have Tesla announcing that it is adding
a 100 kilowatt battery to the Model S
and Model X and it's going to bring down
to zero to sixty to two-and-a-half
seconds from 2.8 seconds Matt there's a
lot of car jargon here which I don't
understand what you do very well but
what you're saying is this is gonna be a
super powerful car that will now appeal
to sports car enthusiasts it's
definitely I mean it's definitely aimed
at someone who cares about numbers right
this is you already had so much power in
a Tesla at the equivalent of about 700
horsepower for all-wheel-drive no other
production car that you could buy
offered that much already
the previous p90d except for maybe the
dodge challenger hellcat and of course
that was only rear-wheel drive this is
going to be more powerful than that and
still be all-wheel drive so it's gonna I
mean be able to propel the car more
quickly than I can with a motorcycle if
you can understand that the amount of
weight that this car I mean it's got to
be more than 3000 pounds so it's
incredible that they're gonna be able to
do this on top of that we knew that Elon
Musk was going to make this announcement
he said it was gonna be a big product
announcement that came mid day and it
pushed the stock up for however
following this announcement you can see
the stock took a leg lower and has
briefly erased his losses it's now kind
of flirting around the unchanged line
actually it's now up 1.1 percent but
certainly a lot lower than what it was I
think that really strikes me watching
Matt gets so excited about this
announcement a lot of people criticize
Tesla and they criticize Elon Musk and
they say oh it's all built on government
subsidies and government picking winners
and all that stuff but it's a pretty
impressive technological engineering
feat regardless of the underlying it's
unbelievable and one of the things that
Elon Musk is doing is winning the battle
of you know renewable power versus
carbon carbon fuels you know a lot of
times gear heads like me will say I want
an internal combustion engine you know
I'm not as concerned about pollution I
just want to put power to the wheels and
this proves that you can do it in a more
efficient way with a battery and a
battery that doesn't weigh as much as
the entire car it's just an impressive
feat I think as far as the stock action
is concern
there's partly some buy on the rumour
selling the news going on here in Tesla
the other thing is a lot of the sources
I was reading about earlier this
afternoon to try and figure out what
Elon was going to say we're pointing
towards a software update for the
autopilot system
maybe investors would have preferred to
see that but as a car lover I'm so happy
that this is what we